luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys anna welcome back to
my show i'm super excited to chat to you all
we had a week off but we're back so it's gonna
be really exciting so as always as you know
it is powered by icon plus capital so a quick
news update for you so actually on april the
25th icons d5 platform balance will be released
a user-friendly platform that creates ics tokens
pegged to real-world assets like the dollar
light gold and like oil now before we jump
into this because this one's going to be very
exciting um this is sponsored by block by you
can actually get up to 250 and when you
sign up with them i use them get up to 8.6
interest on your ustc pretty cool all right so
let's bring on today's guest joining me today
is muneeb ali how are you doing today
i'm good thanks thanks for having me
yeah i'm really excited to chat to you um because
this topic is fascinating to me because you have
these two worlds right you've got like this
narrative that bitcoins this store of value and
then you've got d5 and everything that's going on
there but that's not quite the case is it because
you're trying to essentially bring that onto this
side you're trying to you know do smart contracts
define everything on bitcoin so talk to me about
this yeah so i think i think there's there's a big
misconception out there that uh bitcoin is like
a hard rock and it can't do anything interesting
like in like if you think about it bitcoin has
a blockchain where the original designers have
taken certain design decisions to keep
it relatively simple at the base layer
and that's completely fine because you can build
the rest of the functionality outside of the core
bitcoin blockchain right like their tools come
to mind with sidechains and other other type of
technologies so it's just a kind of like a
technical design decision that do you really want
to do it at the base there or do you want to do it
like around the base layer uh and we bring smart
contracts to bitcoin by not modifying bitcoin at
all but uh basically building a separate system
stacks that connects to bitcoin that settles
transactions on bitcoin and brings smart contracts
there and if you compare that to other systems
like ethereum and other ecosystems uh over there
they would have more native support for smart
contracts right at the base layer but that's
just like a technical detail there's nothing
fundamental about doing it this way or that way
a lot of the time when we talk about um building
this kind of ecosystem on top of bitcoin there's
a huge criticism that you know it would mean
compromising security decentralization but
i'm assuming that isn't the case because
you're not changing the actual fundamental
technology yes so i think uh so i i have a
distributed systems uh background so i've
been i've been kind of like doing research work
in this area for for more than a decade and so
and uh discovered bitcoin around 2013 and
even from back then it was abundantly clear
that you can't scale the base layer to do millions
of transactions or store like an insane amount of
data there or to have full smart contracts at the
base layer because you open for smart contracts
especially with like you know full tiering
complete languages you're opening yourself
up to certain attack factors that you really don't
want at the at the basic and similarly like the
bitcoin blockchain is not a place to store user
data or to store like tons of information and
we saw that in the um in in the big blocks small
block type of wars right like people who forked
off who wanted to basically store a lot of data
in the bitcoin blockchain that that doesn't really
work that way right bitcoin is really a settlement
layer only the most important transactions are
going to happen on bitcoin it is a store of value
and just like the lightning network settles a lot
of uh transactions directly on the bitcoin
function the stacks blockchain does the same
thing right so you can do thousands or potentially
down the road millions of transactions on stacks
and they would just set you on bitcoin but they're
benefiting from the security of the base layer
which is the critical thing to understand here
right because everything that is settling on
bitcoin is benefiting from the proof of work from
the security of the bitcoin blockchain because
once that transaction settles on bitcoin like you
would have to go and reorg bitcoin to be able to
change the history of that right so those are the
the benefits and at a high level uh bitcoin by far
is the biggest brand name uh it has the largest
community it has over a trillion dollars of
crypto capital and most people are going to get
introduced to crypto through bitcoin like bitcoin
is the first thing that they uh that they hear
about and then interestingly you know developers
would be like oh i can't really program bitcoin
at the base layer and then they would discover
ethereum or some other blockchain but 99 of the
developers have never written a smart contract yet
right so the future developers would discover
bitcoin and then be like oh cool i can also
program bitcoin here are a bunch of different
options there are some programming languages
and i think that's that that's kind of like my my
vision of the world of like where where things go
but if you're just building on top of it right
and so you ha you have the bitcoin network which
maintains the security so that's not changing and
you can rely on that what you're building on top
how do we know that that is secure and the
reason i ask this is because one of the biggest
um criticisms of everything that isn't bitcoin
is just the fact that it's not proof of work and
it's not bitcoin and it's just not bitcoin right
and that's kind of what what it comes down to so
this is another layer of technology that isn't
bitcoin so how can we trust it why is it not
why is it not the same as you know another layer
on top of ethereum given i know obviously the
ethereum layer one is different yeah so i think
think of this way that theoretically we could have
started a separate layer one proof-of-work network
which is actually what ethereum did right like
ethereum started the separate google work network
and now you have a different set of miners who are
doing proof of work on bitcoin and a different set
of miners with a different algorithm for for the
for the hashes that they're calculating for
doing proof of work uh on ethereum and ethereum
has plans for moving to proof of stake and so
on and we can we can we can separate that out
but fundamentally speaking you're actually
not sharing the compute power of bitcoin
you're you're starting a separate network and this
is the this is the exact thing that we wanted to
avoid in the sense that what we have figured out
is consensus between blockchains right now usually
a blockchain system would just have consensus on
at a single blockchain level so we figured out a
consensus protocol between two blockchains between
bitcoin and stacks and what happens is that our uh
stacks is completely dependent on bitcoin for for
survival right like we are we are not competing
with bitcoin we are not trying to be money uh this
tax cryptocurrency is a uh asset that is used as
gas uh for smart contracts right and it completely
depends on bitcoin for even survival and our
miners work on the bitcoin chain right so instead
of doing proof of work they are actually uh
we have a new mechanism called proof of transfer
where it's like they're using bitcoin to secure
this tax chain right so it's a little bit like
you've already produced bitcoin by doing proof of
work now just use the bitcoin as as almost like
proof of computation and use that to secure a
blockchain that kind of like depends on on bitcoin
but the the critical difference here is uh once
the transactions settle on bitcoin you would have
to go and reorg bitcoin uh to be able to change
that history right whereas if you had a separate
system then the security of the blockchain really
depends on the security of that completely
separate uh separate system in blockchain
you have nothing to do with bitcoin at that point
and obviously the lightning network is very much
to do with literally just speeding up transactions
so would you say that what you're doing is similar
to that just with more added features essentially
yes it is very similar in design and uh
so people who understand lightning network
think of it this way that you have to set up
uh the nodes in a lightning channel and then you
can actually do fast transactions and that at some
point the channel is going to go and settle on
bitcoin so the way we design stacks is uh that
that there are miners who are effectively they
already have these channels open all the time
and they're settling by default every single
bitcoin block so every single bitcoin block
all the transactions that happen on the stack
side they automatically set on a bitcoin so you
don't have to worry about who's setting up the
channels who's actually going to settle on on the
chain and then the biggest difference is actually
the clarity smart contract programming language
so clarity is a new smart contract programming
language that has full visibility into bitcoin
meaning that you can developers can start
building smart contracts uh where they're
actually programming against bitcoin state which
is super exciting because you know bitcoin is
a trillion dollars in capital and i think
i think uh developers would want to do very
very interesting things for them so how are you
then different because you have some competitors
out there and there's rsk there's liquid btc so
what's the difference there yeah so i think first
of all like i'm a i'm a bitcoiner at heart and
yeah i love all these different efforts because
in my mind these are different design points
that people are exploring so in terms of rsk
i think they are more in the camp of trying to be
a really true side chain in the sense that they
don't have a separate uh asset for for gas and
transactions and they're focusing on trying to
move bitcoin from the bitcoin chain using that as
as the asset and then and bringing that back right
so liquid is also more in that cam uh you have so
so rska does uh merge mining right so a subset of
the bitcoin miners would actually also mine on the
rsk chain and in terms of of liquid they have a
slightly different design so they also have a peg
asset called uh called liquid bdc and uh you can
you can transfer that into the liquid chain but
on the way back you have to trust a federation
right so it's like a somewhat of a semi federated
model where where uh to get the bitcoin back from
liquid chain into the into the bitcoin blockchain
you have to kind of trust the figuration and and
again i'm not that's going to be some yes but
these are these are different design choices right
so people whoever feel comfortable with whatever
design choice like for example i understand that
that some people in the bitcoin community are not
going to like the fact that stacks has a different
asset right yeah if you want to be if you want to
be very much on one end of the spectrum that you
believe in just one asset maybe you would uh you
would be more uh inclined to use a network where
there's no other asset but but interesting i have
a question on that point though i have a question
on that point though so if so why do you have
why do you have your own asset i know you said
for gatsbys but is it even possible you know i'm
not super techy i don't know is it possible to do
what you're doing without that it can you not just
be bitcoin only in it exactly so i think these are
the trade-offs right that because we have the
new asset our mining is actually permissionless
you don't have to rely on a on a federation
because miners have incentives right so mining
is permissionless secondly these miners have
incentives to store the extra smart contract
state you don't want to put that data the smart
contract logic into the bitcoin blockchain itself
right so because of the stacks asset these
miners have an incentive to store that data
right and keep that data alive and finally
that is the asset that is being used for gas
so you have to whenever whenever you're asking
another party to do computations for you you
have to basically pay them right and that payment
is in is in stacks and if you were trying to make
it in bitcoin like my like it would actually
be extremely expensive right like bitcoin is
is is a very expensive asset and we have actually
tried that some earlier versions of our system
were directly trying to build on top of bitcoin
directly trying to actually use bitcoin as the
asset and very quickly you were in situations
where let's say you're trying to register a three
dollar domain name and you're paying a 50 bucks in
in transaction fees on that three dollar of worth
of transactions right and also the bitcoin core
developers would hate the fact that now you're
storing all that additional data into the bitcoin
blockchain itself right so we revise our design
and the sax blockchain that launched two months
ago uh actually does not make any changes to
bitcoin at all does not write any additional
data uh on the bitcoin side and and effectively
you can do cheap transactions that are that
are they're settling on bitcoin automatically
so what would you say the main reason for doing
this is then because right now we have d5 okay so
ethereum is is slightly broken potentially we've
got 82.0 coming at some point one day but you know
this finance smart chain a lot there's been a
massive um you know migration and move to bsc
so right now bitcoin has really adopted that store
of value narrative i mean people like elon musk
and michael saylor they're not buying into bitcoin
for any d5 purposes they're buying into bitcoin
because it's gold 2.0 so is this necessary like
why of course it's necessary because you're doing
it but why is why would you say it's necessary why
can't you just leave it as it is and let finance
do as they're doing and all the other you know
projects polkadot and so on yeah no that's a great
question so i think let's let's play it out uh
bitcoin is kind of like winning the sort of value
uh use case so let's say we start getting more and
more capital right now we're at one trillion maybe
it goes to two trillion three trillion and right
and that's saved as bitcoin now people want to do
useful things with that capital and what you're
noticing is that people would have things like
uh synthetic bitcoin assets like wrapped bitcoin
and they're so in in wrapped bitcoin let's look
at the user flow first of all there's a custodian
in the middle uh so you're getting a tax hit when
you're going from bitcoin to wrapped bitcoin and
then back you're actually now introducing a tech
stack that maybe bitcoiners don't want to trust
because now rap bitcoin is being issued on top
of a theory right so in some ways they're taking a
tax head they're going through a custodial and now
their asset is on on a technology stack that they
might consider to be too experimental uh and and
they're taking additional risk there versus
imagine that a bitcoin lending application
where uh built on stacks because tax is doing
the reverse of that instead of taking an
asset to a different blockchain it's bringing the
smart contracts to bitcoin right so once you have
smart contracts on bitcoin directly uh you can
have a lending application where your bitcoin is
just going from a pure bitcoin address to another
pure bitcoin address on the main chain as the as
as the lending side of it and the smart
contract logic lives on the stack side that
has a collateral and can release the collateral
automatically if your loan doesn't come back so
i think it actually reduces a lot of complexity uh
it's a much more simpler approach and it it cuts
out a lot of the the custodians or risk factors
and other other blockchains so i think the model
to think about really here is that once you have
so much capital locked up as bitcoin people would
want to do interesting things with it like they
would want to have bitcoin lending they would want
to deploy that capital uh to provide liquidity
or have other other types of use cases and what
we're doing is we're basically bringing the use
cases to bitcoin treating bitcoin as a center of
gravity versus being in this weird sort of a world
where people are trying to issue synthetic assets
uh on on top of other chains right and you you
mentioned a couple of efforts there i would also
like to point out that there's also a bitcoin
way of building things right where a bitcoin
way did you say a bitcoin way of doing yeah
like like like if you look at the bitcoin stack
uh the the quality bar for for for the technology
is actually very very high right people are very
much concerned about the security of the code base
they're very concerned about uh you know consensus
issues and so on so whenever you're you're
adding something more experimental to the mix
it will actually give pause to a lot of bitcoiners
that they might not want to use that technology
so with with stacks one thing that we're really
trying to do is we're trying to focus a lot
on these things that we we use bitcoin as much
as possible for security uh our smart contract
language is actually uh you can have formal
proofs of verification there so so people can
feel feel safe that this contract can only do what
it's supposed to do and can't do anything else
and and best of all it's a permissionless system
right so you mentioned the binance smart contracts
there are like 15 or so nodes that it's it's
again a federated network they're 15 or so
nodes that are controlling that finance smart
chain and i think that might not go that well
with a lot of bitcoiners who are are believers in
in decentralization and permissionless things and
and basically doing things uh that that
are more clearly on one end of the spectrum
yeah i think that's a massive um criticism
of uh binary smart chain that i keep hearing
even in comparison to to ethereum but okay so
everything that we're seeing right now is taking
time especially with eats 2.0 um and i really feel
there's there's some there's just huge competition
there's a lot of talk um obviously i was
doing a lot of research about stacks before
our interview there's a lot of talk about
whether you guys are looking to replace ethereum
but you're not looking to replace ethereum are
you yeah i would i would say that there is some
overlap but there is definitely a lot of a lot
of green field as well like for example there
are certain applications that are possible
on stacks that are simply not possible on
popular theory right i'll give you one example
yeah uh so we have this uh px contract where
people can lock up lock-up capital and they're
earning bitcoin as a yield and these are pure
bitcoin transactions on the bitcoin blockchain so
people you if you lock up capital there like you
are actually getting a bitcoin yield and it's
around 10 so we launched around two months ago
and over that time uh we first got 100 million
uh total value locked and 200 then 300 then 400
and i think last week it crossed a billion dollars
right so within two months we are actually seeing
uh traction on a smart contract where people
can lock up capital and earn bitcoin and these
types of functionality would be impossible or
at least very very hard to do on blockchains
that are separate from bitcoin and that are not
kind of like directly building on top and that's
just one use case imagine different types of
bitcoin yields different types of stable coins
that are actually backed by bitcoin that actually
settle on bitcoin and so on so i would say there
is a lot of green field of innovation directly on
top of bitcoin where we are not competing with it
with ethereum or other chains and then there are
overlapping areas like for example if someone is
trying to issue nfts uh on the edm chain well you
can do that on on top of bitcoin now through two
stacks and so on and there would be a subset of
these applications i think ethereum is it will
it is likely going to survive in one form and
another for years to come uh i've been a skeptic
of e2 purely from a computer science uh like
technical design perspective and i think they
have morphed the design several times it still
keeps changing although there's a lot of kind
of like marketing hype around it and people are
getting excited as if uh e2 is about to happen
but i think it's it's years and years out and it
is not in its final form uh at all at this point
yeah not at all but so what's the reception
been um from the bitcoin community i've been
really fascinated because when we had that whole
d5 summer uh but people were just sort of saying
you know bitcoin as melee was saying d5 is just a
scam um but i wonder whether they don't feel that
way now that it's sort of going to be built on top
of bitcoin i don't know what's the reception been
yeah so i think uh i would i would
separate separate out two things one is um
useful things you can do with decentralized
finance i think that actually a lot of
bitcoiners would like that like why do i need
to depend on a bank or a financial institution
for for taking a loan out like imagine a bitcoiner
is like hey i want to give bitcoin collateral
and i want to take out a stable currency like
a usdc loan right use it and then give it back
because i don't want to sell my bitcoin
that's defy but that's the kind of d5 that
they're going to love that yes i don't don't
want to sell bitcoin i'm not trusting anyone
and you know i'm taking a loan loan from a from
from a smart contract or the other way around
that i want to lend out my bitcoin in a trustless
way and earn interest on it because i don't want
to sell my bitcoin right so these are all d5
applications and and bitcoiners would like the
decentralization aspect of it i think where
they get more hung up is sometimes the more
experimental nature of things on ethereum or other
systems or the kind of like the marketing and the
hype around some of the these these new assets and
how it's it feels a little bit like gambling and i
think that's where uh there's a almost like a cult
like a cultural reaction that hey we don't like
that type of activity and we would just rather
stay out of it i don't but i don't think that
uh if you talk about like useful applications
that are decentralizing finance like they are
quite appealing to to a lot of bitcoiners
and interestingly i'll mention something
so i think overall i would say the reception
for stacks since the launch two two months or
so ago has been really well there are obviously
uh bitcoin hardliners who just don't who are very
skeptical of any new type of an asset like doesn't
matter what that asset is they just don't like it
and interestingly uh sometimes people would be
skeptical of the stacks asset when you need it
and you would have to get into a discussion
like the one we did that it actually ensures
permission that's mining it gives incentives for
miners to keep that data because you do want to
keep that data outside of bitcoin and and so on
but then they would have like some sort of uh
some sort of a moment where they're like okay it's
a new asset i generally don't like new assets but
this asset earns bitcoin right i do want to earn
bitcoin though right so they would have like that
moment where where they would actually uh start
getting more curious and start start learning
more more about the project so there's a bit
that i'm still not 100 on which i just want to
get right in my head because you you made a tweet
the other day and you also spoke about it just now
the the idea of lending with bitcoin so i love
that because i'm one of those people that will
never sell their bitcoin dad asks me what my
pension plan is i say it's bitcoin like that's
that's a serious conversation we're having um
but you said there's no counterparty risk you
just have to trust the network but how can we
trust the network because it's not because i
i know of course we've got the bitcoin base
layer but how can we trust the stacks network
sure you know because it's not bitcoin yes
that's what i can't get my head around the
the way to think about this is that any system
that's kind of like an extension of bitcoin
yes it introduces some risks but you can
understand but you can understand those risks like
for example if you're using the lightning channel
you can try to understand what what my risks are
and what would happen if things go wrong right so
this is where stax comes in and why we focused a
lot on the clarity smart contract language uh
so the clarity language has formal verification
meaning that if you're doing uh let's say there's
a lending application built built uh both using
it so you're lending your bitcoin and what
you're trusting it that here's a smart contract
that has let's say 200 collateralized uh
some sort of a stable coin called a usdc loan
so your risk factor is that if by a certain
bitcoin block my bitcoin doesn't come back
is the collateral going to automatically release
to me or not right and you can have formal
verifications that yes this smart contract will
release you know usdc to you if if your if your
bitcoin doesn't come back because this smartphone
rack actually has full visibility into bitcoin
you're actually trusting the bitcoin state so
the smart contract knows about bitcoin blocks
the smart contract knows about when money moves on
bitcoin right so the logic in the smart contract
is saying if bitcoin x amount of bitcoin does not
come back to this address by this block number the
smart contract is going to release the collateral
to your address and then you can go and buy
buy more bitcoin you mentioned um nfts earlier and
i really want to talk about that because obviously
that's going to be part of all of this but before
we go into that where do you stand on nfts because
i think the the hype is slowly dying down um
of course bitcoiners don't like it um so so
where do you stand do you think it's a bubble
or do you think there's some actual value there
i think i think there is definitely a lot
of hype around it but uh i i think there's
definitely signal amongst all of the noise like
there are some very interesting real applications
and i am one of those people who always want to
focus on the signal and kind of like ignore the
noise the noise is going to go away at some point
interestingly the interesting thing about nfts is
that nfts are actually a very old concept like
i'm actually seeing some some talk in circles
that nfts were invented on ethereum and i'm like
scratching my head because uh domain names are
nfts like non-fungible tokens and the very first
fork of bitcoin namecoin i've actually worked on
it i'm i'm i'm og enough in this space that i
actually have hacked on namecoin i've worked on
the endpoint this is like 2013. and namecoin was
effectively a fork of bitcoin introducing nfts
and those nfts were uh domain names right and then
we have seen things like counterparty on bitcoin
where we had rare pepes and other types of
entities on top of the bitcoin chain and some of
the difficulties with these things i think those
challenges are still there for example namecoin
was a merged mind chain with bitcoin again those
types of questions that do you want to share the
compute power of the bitcoin do you want to build
this separate network and and with counterparty
you were actually storing a lot of information on
the main bitcoin chain and it was a bit clunky and
so on and early days i think it's the same set
of underlying technical challenges that in many
ways like we work on with stacks where we're like
okay this thing is not merged mine this thing is
permissionless uh you are not storing the data on
the bitcoin chain and you can have nfts you can
have domain names uh you can have other types
of digital art and that is secured by bitcoin
when you're talking about nfts and their ownership
and their provenance uh like what better way to
store the ownership information than the bitcoin
blockchain that's going to be there uh a hundred
years from now and so on right and and you don't
want to uh kind of like become a scalability
problem for the bitcoin blockchain that's why
you want to settle uh thousands of transactions
on bitcoin in a single transaction instead
of like every time there's a sale of an nft
you're paying like a hundred dollars on the main
blockchain to actually record that information
but you didn't tell me i don't know do
you think it's a bubble or do you think
there's genuine value i think i think they're uh
in the long term there's genuine value right in
the short term we might be in a bubble where a lot
of people who have kind of like formered into nfts
when the markets turn a little bit they would
realize that they're holding highly illiquid
assets and and the prices have actually gone
down and nobody's willing to buy these things
so i think the the way to think about this is
i am very bullish on the underlying technology
in future use cases uh but i definitely think that
in the short term there there there's a bubble and
you know it's gonna it's gonna burst or something
yeah i think it's a really interesting one because
i've always said i can see value in it just given
everything is gone digital it just makes sense
that even physical items would have some kind of
tokenized um identity on the blockchain just to
verify whether it be um you know like a designer
handbag or a watch or whatever it is you know
ornaments just to give an actual you
know you can track the whole supply
chain to me i find value in that the whole
bubble that's kind of where i'm not sure about
yeah i mean they're they're already things online
like i think domain names are actually a perfect
example it's a purely digital asset has nothing
to do with the real world it has value like domain
names have been around for decades now people
pay a lot of money for for domain names domain
names are nfts they and similarly if you look
at a lot of games any in-game asset is actually
an nft it could very easily be converted to an
nft and people are paying money for these things
like they're they're paying money to get an avatar
in a video game they're paying money to actually
buy and resell things and what nfts kind of
like do is that they define ownership at a
global scale so you can actually take things
from one video game sell it on a secondary
market somewhere outside and that's a that's a
that's a pretty pretty kind of like a huge market
and i also wanted to learn a little bit more about
you on a more casual level like how did you get
into crypto where did your journey start yeah it's
interesting actually uh yesterday a friend of mine
sent me a clip of a talk i was giving at the at
the princeton club here in new york it was in 2014
i think there were some uh uh comments
there where i was telling people that
i am 100 in bitcoin like i actually cash out to
uh eat right like and in 2014 in hindsight like
that turned out to be a really good decision but
my journey has been that uh i'm i'm a computer
scientist i did my phd at princeton and i have
always been working on uh internet protocols like
next generation internet protocols cloud computing
uh like high scalability distributed systems and
so on and i was actually working originally
on almost like a next generation internet
architecture there have been many such efforts in
academia at princeton stanford and other places
but none of them got commercialized and
that really bothered me right so i wanted to
almost like build this thing out as a commercial
entity that what would a future more secure more
decentralized internet look like and discovered
blockchains on the way right so this is this is
2013 when uh me and my co-founder we discovered
uh blockchains and that fundamental question of
should we build on bitcoin should we build
on namecoin which is like a merge mine
chain or three should we start a separate
blockchain your camera's gone a little bit
is it is it better oh i think we're back all
right yeah yeah very good yeah sorry go on yeah
so i think that that question of like you know
should you build directly on bitcoin should you
work on a merge line chain like name coin or
three should you go off and start a separate block
i think that is literally still the question
that people are asking even right now
that hey should you build on bitcoin should
you build on ethereum which is a separate chain
or should you build on something something like
rsk which is which is merged right and i think
i think uh over there over the years from the
lessons that we have learned i think we have
uh we are pretty much in the camp that there will
be more experimentation in the short term there
will be many different blockchains many different
types of experiments but in the long term i think
we'll see consolidation on top of bitcoin
and that's that's our core thesis that any
uh any application or smart contract that
actually finds a product market fit will
eventually exist in some form on top of bitcoin
which is the bigger market and more more secure
i think what really fascinates me about all of
this is the fact that it is just so experimental
and i've been following um rao powell's kind
of interaction and journey through this space
um because i think at one point he was 90 in
bitcoin 80 in eth and now he's really delved into
many other different things and he's very much
of the mindset which i i sort of i do share this
mindset i for me bitcoin is number one and i just
won't sell it it's just not happening um but i am
interested in all sorts of other innovation that's
happening and i think that we have to i don't i'm
not i just i think it's just reductionist to be
so close-minded and not and not open your eyes
and see what else is coming along it doesn't mean
that what else is coming on along is necessarily
going to replace bitcoin or be better but i just
think everything is so early we always go on about
how early everything is and how early we are and
we just don't know what's coming next so i just
feel that we i i'm open to seeing everything
and hearing about all the different projects
and seeing you know what comes of it yeah i think
definitely like humans are curious-minded people
right so even if you're like i've i've i've pretty
much been in the bitcoin camp since the beginning
but i've kept kept like a small pocket i've called
it like five percent 10 experimentation especially
if they're people that like and trust and they're
trying to do something interesting like like juan
at fault coin is is a colleague of mine i like
i would i would i would back them right i'll
see like what happens it's a it's an interesting
ambitious project let's see let's see what happens
over there but i think the this mentality of
actually uh like bitcoiners i can see their point
of view as well like they've actually seen the
story play out several times over like whenever
you're in a bull market uh sometimes the more
experimental things end up getting more attention
because they're very risky but they might be maybe
showing better returns right like safe moon you
remember you saw moonlight like that that was
wild yeah i heard heard some things about it but
but then given a long enough timeline like these
more experimental things then crash very hard as
well right so if you have actually lost bitcoin
in kind of like trading these assets like you
uh you you have those those scars right and you
want to be extremely careful of uh of engaging
there yeah and i i totally get that um i i just
think that the hostility is is quite unbelievable
um so it always blows my mind but listen i'm
wondering we have a lot of questions coming
through so i'm wondering whether you'd be open
to do a quick ama um if i throw some questions
on the screen yep happy too all right cool so
guys if you do have any questions then just drop
them below in the chat now because we're gonna
answer some of them so i'm just gonna go through
i think my wi-fi is cutting in and out maybe i
don't know um but here we go let's have a look
is he okay having jack associated with their
project is jack associated with your project
ceo jack yeah jack is not a investor in the
project but i have connected with him on twitter
he's a bitcoiner he's very excited about seeing
more innovation on bitcoin but he's officially
i don't think he's a uh he is a measure of
the product okay someone has also asked um
about hiro they've said that they're excited about
the platform if you can give any updates on that
yes so i think uh my company did the early r d
and public infrastructure building and once we
launched the the stacks 2.0 blockchain two three
months ago we clearly separated out the open
source project uh stacks from my company right so
my company focuses on developer tools for for uh
for the system and what we're doing is effectively
building out all the developer tools that people
would need and the and the latest version that
we announced today the the hero platform it's
meant to be a hosted service that makes it super
easy for developers to uh deploy apps and smart
contracts on top of stacks and bitcoin right
so think of it that the underlying network is
open and decent life but we want to make lives or
developers as easy as possible give them all the
right tools the apis uh to make it super simple
to build built on top of bitcoin and this one's
fun so could we give a tip about the next game
changer in crypto so i actually asked my community
this the other day we've had icos we've had d5
we've had nfts what earth do you think is next
yeah so i think i think interestingly i would
say that my experience in crypto has been that
there are ideas that are around for a while but
the conditions are not right for them to kind of
take off i think nfts are a great example they're
by far not a new thing like they've been around
for years and years but suddenly the market
conditions were right for them to kind of like
go mainstream uh similarly i think uh decent
by social networks or or decentralized identity
it's an idea that has been around in
crypto again like five six years now
but it might be that there is there are some
market conditions like down the road i don't know
if it's going to be next year a couple of years
from now where suddenly uh it just feels like
oh my god everyone is moving to a crypto social
network everyone is everyone now has their own
kind of like crypto identity and they're kind
of like moving away from the facebooks of the
world like that that would be one one of
the things that i would like watch out for
so that's really interesting i'm so torn when it
comes to um when it comes to those sorts of things
so decentralized social media applications because
we're trying to do that um with there are quite
a few but it's so hard to bring people over isn't
it um number one people won't want to pay for for
content you know they want it free twitter's free
instagram facebook youtube is all basically free
because we're the product um and i i just
it's hard to bring people over and with
user experience not being so great i mean hive
wasn't the easiest of user experiences you know
just as an example it just wasn't um how likely
do you think that actually is you know because
user experience matters yes i think there are
there are several challenges uh ux is one of them
uh i think it's also kind of like network effects
as well like what incentives do people have to
move over but i think like the same same thing
with with some of the other other stuff right
like even the d5 it's like a marketplace like
you need to have liquidity you need to have the
right right protocols you need to have enough
of incentives for people who can like move over
but once the stars line up and i think there
has been slow and steady progress suddenly
it feels like oh this happened overnight but that
thing actually didn't happen overnight it was like
years and years and years of work in different
directions when it finally clicked and i think
it's entirely possible that a decent life social
network comes around a couple of years from now
when the ux challenges have been solved when the
incentivization uh is actually like like like much
better understood that why would people move over
and and more more importantly why would people
move over with their distribution and networks
intact right so it's actually better for them like
when the content creators switch over because
they're making more money on a decentralized
social network than a centralized one like i think
they will pull their their distribution with them
right and i i don't know what that magic moment
is like but i can see the slow and steady progress
towards over the years and just final question
for you then um bitcoin price i have to ask you
when you don't have to give us a prediction i
won't put the pressure on you but what are your
thoughts on the general market because right now
i'm looking at the price about 40 54 sorry 0.5
a lot of people say that we are slowly parachuting
down now we're not going to have a sharp snapback
we're slowly parachuting down a lot of people
say well also let's say about 60 70 of the way
through the bull market where do you think we're
at right now yeah so i think interestingly um
like i'm i'm buying more bitcoin like i have buy
orders yes at 50 000 and so on i've been i've been
buying since bitcoin was 90 so i'm a long-term
holder and uh to me it doesn't feel like we're
at the end of this this bull market again this
is just not investment advice this is just my
personal observations uh i i wouldn't be
surprised if we see a hundred thousand uh
bitcoin in this bull market like i i do have the
the laser eyes on on my twitter but uh but from
i'm just sharing what i personally do like
i'm buying at 50 and uh you know if you cross
100k that would feel like okay that was a lot of
progress for a single single cycle yeah absolutely
i think we're kind of at a strange point in in
the cycle where a lot of people i don't know we
don't know where where it's going i also feel
i have i i sort of gauge a sentiment that we're
around 60 70 the way through this bull market i'm
still hoping for 100k this year um but but we'll
see um manipu so where can people find you um what
are you working on um just tell us about yourself
and where they can find you yeah so i think i'm
i'm fairly active on twitter uh i'm at the neeb
m-u-n-e-e-b and for people who want to learn more
about smart contracts for bitcoin they can go to
stacks dot co and stacks is a open source project
there are actually several entities behind it
and then you can learn about all the different
work that these different entities are doing and
the different app developers and the interesting
things that they're building on top of bitcoin
manip i want to thank you so much it's been
really interesting i've been so fascinated about
this entire topic um especially because i've been
spending a lot of time in clubhouse rooms and you
really gauge the i don't know if you so much time
on there um but you gauge the the maximalism um so
i i've been i've been interested to see uh what's
happening basically on bitcoin yeah clubhouse is
great and it's great to connect with the bitcoin
community there yeah absolutely thank you so
much for coming on and guys thank you so much for
watching thank you to the sponsors block find luno
and um icon plus of course and we will see you
all next week bye awesome thanks for having me bye